[Musik]
prima oder na ja noch nicht ganz es
fehlt noch ein gewisses bot drängen gehe
ich mit dem mittelfinger auf kontakt mit
der handschelle ja wohl sehr gut aus wie
das aussehen wird schlägt der vorstädter
[Musik]
meine herren willkommen zur mission
talking heads unser ziel ist die
evakuierung von zwei piloten nach einer
notlandung im sektor kilo 7 feindliche
kräfte im einsatz haben mit widerstand
ist zu rechnen
feuer unterstützung des daad und 5 und
pc 7 angeforderte tätig zusätzliche
unterstützung durch blackrock und covers
holt unsere jungs daraus wie ist meine
rettung aus der luft ausschaut das
schauen wir uns gemeinsam einmal an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die
[Musik]
zurück am boden ja leider ul dann
gratuliere dann auch einer kleinigkeit
für dich bei uns ist es so was wie ein
orden und der gehört daher
ich bleibe hier sitzen drinnen
danke für die tolle erfahrung sagt schon
profis bei der arbeit das war wirklich
beeindruckt sind also auch das serie
training was am boden alles gelernt
werden kann um ebenfalls zu überleben
aber vor allem natürlich die
unterschiedlichen einsatzmöglichkeiten
das des bundesheeres in der luft das war
schon wirklich
ja wenn ich ein resümee ziehen müsste
würde sagen überhaupt da hab ich den
helm behalten und dass da immer so aus
wie tom cruise
[Musik]